the Trump legal troubles continue to get
more Troublesome as one of Trump's outs
has apparently been taken off the table
if Trump were to be convicted at the
federal level he could still run for
president when and then theoretically
pardon himself
if Trump were to be convicted at the
state level however say in Georgia he
would theoretically not be able to
Pardon himself kind of up in the air we
don't we've never been here before
but it theoretically couldn't because
State pardons are at the discretion of
the state and in the case of Georgia he
could not even rely on Republican
Governor Brian Kemp to Pardon him one
because Kemp hates Trump and two because
in Georgia the governor oddly enough
does not even have the power to issue
pardons in Georgia that power lies with
the State Board of Pardons and paroles
which has five members the majority of
whom hate Trump and even if they love
Trump the board members have to wait
according to statute until a convict has
served at least five years of his
sentence before even considering his
application
now some lawyers disagree Mark Levin
insists that Trump can in fact pardon
himself even in Georgia because the
Constitution silent about whether a
president can be indicted he says the
doj under both parties has said that you
can't indict a sitting president because
it would the executive branch
and because quote the supremity clause
and the supremacy clause rather in the
Constitution prevents local DA's from
Prosecuting presidents because the
effect of those indictments would
practically be no different from a
Federal indictment it would just take
out the executive branch and you know
what my take on all of that is
yeah sure
sure whatever
Mark Levin is a sharp guy he's a sharp
lawyer his legal arguments sound fine to
me but also
this is not about legal arguments
the Liberals arrested the former
president and current opposition leader
for recommending a TV show on Twitter
we are so past the point of serious
legal arguments
I keep hearing if such and such happens
if if the libs do such and such then
they'll really have crossed the Rubicon
they've already arrested the opposition
leader they're threatening him with more
than 700 years in prison
they're timing the trials to prevent him
from winning the presidential election
at what point do we admit
that they have crossed the Rubicon
already I'm Michael nolsys the Michael
Knowles show
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the show we've got
breaking news this morning that lady
playing the new Snow White continues to
be insufferable we'll get to this
breaking and very important news in just
a moment first though I don't want to
move on from the doj and and from the
the Liberals wielding political power to
protect their own and to attack
conservatives
moving away from Trump for a second
focusing on the bidens you know that
Merrick Garland Biden's attorney general
has just appointed a special counsel in
the case investigating Hunter Biden this
after the Liberals told us there was
nothing to see with Hunter Biden no
evidence of any crime this after the doj
tried to get a sweetheart deal for
Hunter Biden that would allow him to
avoid any consequences and avoid Joe
Biden to invite any any scrutiny about
the weird money that was coming into the
Biden's family bank accounts from
overseas from Ukraine and Kazakhstan and
all sorts of other places so then
Garland appoints the guy who had been
completely blowing perhaps intentionally
the hunter Biden case he appoints that
guy to become the special counsel to be
able to continue the case that he seems
intentionally to have tried to blow for
the past several years to to have him
continue that investigation with even
less scrutiny with even less oversight
than he previously had to which Alan
dershowitz
a very great
famous credible Harvard professor and
legal scholar
that came out and he said that that
appointment is illegal
Allen said citing uh section 600.3 c of
the code of federal regulations quote
special counsel is supposed to be
independent of the current government
not an employee who serves as U.S
attorney for Delaware and can be fired
from that job by the president
it's very clear in the in this code that
the special counsel has to be quote
selected from outside the U.S government
so by by raising this guy who was
already working for Garland already
working for Biden just some doj lawyer
who had been
slow walking and and trying to trying to
push aside this Hunter Biden Case by by
elevating him to be the special counsel
you completely undermine the whole point
of the special counsel and you violate
the law to which I say much as I would
say to Mark Levin
yeah
sure
uh-huh sounds good to me but like
whatever
they're behaving illegally
they don't care about the law
of course they don't care about the
special section of the Federal
Regulation that determines which kind of
lawyers can be elevated to special
counsel these are people who kill babies
and cast straight children they don't
care about the special little regulation
of the law and it's sad I I'm not saying
that we should stop making legal
arguments I'm not saying that we should
stop trying to fight all of these absurd
predations by the left in court using
whatever tools we've got but let's at
least be honest with ourselves folks
this has nothing to do with the law
they're not going after Donald Trump
because he made a an in-kind
contribution to his own campaign in
2016. they're not going after Donald
Trump because he made a speech after the
election of 2020 much as
Al Gore did much as Hillary Clinton did
much of Stacy Abrams did they're not
going after Donald Trump because he
picked up the phone and complained about
the prospect of voter fraud in Georgia
to the Secretary of State of Georgia
they're just trying to get him they're
just going to get him and they're going
to use whatever species ridiculous
arguments they can they don't care about
the law they don't care about the
positive law they don't care about the
civil law they certainly don't care
about the Constitutional law they don't
care about the natural law
don't lose sight of the fact that these
people kill babies and castrate children
okay I'm not I'm not mentioning this as
a gratuitous attack on the left or or a
distraction from the issue at hand I'm
just pointing out if you deny such
fundamental aspects of the natural law
of the background principles of justice
that undergird our written law our
constitutional law civil positive law
then you're you're not going to be
making serious legal arguments you're
not going to be treating the law as as
an instrument of Justice which is
objective about which we can deliberate
and and argue you're you're treating the
law as a blunt instrument merely for the
pursuit of your own irrational interests
to Club your enemies over the head which
is exactly what they're doing here and
ideally we would restore some balance
back to our legal and political system
if you want to restore balance to your
body you've got to check out balance of
nature right now go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles living a healthy lifestyle it's
not always easy especially when you're
always on the go you need simple
manageable routines to make sure that
you are getting proper nutrition every
day that's why I'm a huge fan of balance
of nature balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to make sure
you're getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day their
capsules are packed with 100 whole food
that you can take at any time balance of
nature uses a cold vacuum process that
preserves the natural phytonutrients in
whole fruits and veggies and
encapsulates them for easy consumption
balance of nature sent a bunch of their
products down to the studio for our team
to try we all love them was jackals try
to steal them all away from me but but I
think we just need to get balance of
nature to send more make sure you go
check it out right now go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles kwles for 35 off your first
order as a preferred customer that's
balanceofnature.com promo code Knowles
Canada w-l-e-s for 35 off your first
preferred
order
I'll give you a particularly egregious
example of lawlessness
this one not here in
the United States but down in Mexico
uh here we are cartel Hitman
aged 14
beheaded four victims
as Mexico's lawlessness is exposed
this is someone working for the cartel
98 of cartel executions they call them
executions they use legal language much
as the left does in the United States
they use legal language to to defend
their extrajudicial at the very least
unjust
killings and they enlist little kids in
it too
they they enlist little kids in their
perverse and absurd political agenda
much I'm starting to see a lot more
similarities actually between the
Mexican cartels and our political
opponents here in the United States but
why do I mention this 14 year old who
beheaded uh four people
he says
it was just from the article in the
Daily Star
I know one one of the guys who was there
they asked him this this guy's got three
sons and kind of knew how to talk to him
journalists asked this this little
killer said what have you done
and the cartel kids said I have
decapitated four people I was a 14 year
old who said it
I think that kid probably wasn't raised
right
and I
I don't mention it as as just a little
bit of an understatement or as a kind of
a joke I mean
the way that kids are raised is going to
affect the entire state of the country I
was recently going back through
Aristotle's Nico McKeon ethics the first
book on morality and one of the most
important philosophical Works ever
written and
Aristotle in this book tells you here's
how you're happy here's how to be happy
the way to be happy is not synonymous
with being virtuous but it is has a lot
to do with being virtuous it has a lot a
lot to do with being good
good people tend to be happy and the way
to be good is to practice the virtues
and the way to be good is to gain some
intellectual virtue though a lot more of
it is about practicing certain habits
and this is a crucial part it's very
hard for for people to hear in the
Modern Age
you got to be raised right
if you're not raised right it's going to
be a lot harder for you to become
virtuous and to become good and to
become happy
because
being good and being virtuous is not
just about the actions that we do but
being good and being virtuous is also
about the desires that we have you know
a friend of mine says that facts don't
care about your feelings which may be
true but virtue does care about your
feelings
so in Aristotle scheme there are four
kinds of people there's self-indulgent
people people who do bad things and
they're unrepentant they just they're
happy that they do but they're not
really happy but they at least convince
themselves that they enjoy doing bad
things there are incontinent people who
know that they shouldn't do bad things
but they still do them there are
continent people who know that they
shouldn't do bad things and they don't
do them
but it's hard for them not to do them
that it requires grit and endurance and
resistance and I think that's where most
people think it ends I think that most
people think that that explains
bad people to good people but there's a
fourth category
and this is the only category that
Aristotle says is really happy people
and that is virtuous people who not only
do good things but actually get pleasure
from doing good things
and in order to do that it's not that
it's impossible to train yourself to do
that certainly by availing yourself of
God's grace that's going to be a big
help but it's so much harder to do that
if you haven't had those habits of
virtue ingrained into you from the time
you're a kid this is why conservatives
are so focused right now on stopping the
left from from destroying the schools
and in so doing
setting kids up for a lifetime of
failure when the left goes into schools
and inculcates all sorts of deviant
desires and habits and behaviors into
them it's not just going to screw them
up for a couple of years and then as as
child abusers will say oh kids are
resilient they'll bounce back that's not
how it works you form habits and then if
you form good habits it's harder to
break good habits and if you form bad
habits and addictions it's harder to
break those bad habits so we hear about
a 14 year old in Mexico who's now a
crazy psycho killer was beheading four
people and
a lot of people are going to look at
that with curiosity how could a 14 year
old possibly do that how could a 14 year
old go so bad
easily kids are really malleable very
it's very easy to morph a kid's brain
into thinking or even doing all sorts of
things
in fact that's a piece of political
wisdom that everybody had for 2300 years
at least until very very recently the
left still has it that's why the left
focuses on the schools the right forgets
it to some degree and so the right says
oh we don't want to teach people how to
think or what to think rather just how
to think we don't want to indoctrinate
people no of course you do that's what
that's what Early Education is about is
just rote training in certain behaviors
so are you going to teach kids to clean
up their dishes and recite their
alphabet and respect their mother and
father are you going to teach kids to
cut off people's heads and do all sorts
of the Deviant things that the American
left wants them to do that's that's the
question before you but you can't you
can't avoid it that period of Early
Education
is going to account for half more than
half of of what the the people of a
country are going to look like
down the road
if you want to have a good country you
gotta have people who are behaving in a
good way it's as simple as that you
can't have a good country without good
people
speaking of children and bad education
this is the breaking news for the day
uh the lady playing Snow White
who is she's very intentionally not
particularly White
so we've been calling her sand beige
this lady who's a far left-wing
pretty insufferable lady she she's got
another hit take it away
I mean you know the original cartoon
came out in 1937 and very evidently
um with a guy who literally stalks her
yeah weird weird
time so no Prince or a different kind of
Prince we have a different approach to
what I'm sure a lot of people will
assume is a love story just because like
we cast a guy in the movie Andrew burn
up great dude
um it's uh it's one of those things that
I think everyone's gonna have their
assumptions about what it's actually
going to be but uh it's really not about
the love story at all which is really
really wonderful and whether or not she
finds love along the way is anybody's
guess until 2024.
um all of Andrew scenes could get cut
who knows it's Hollywood baby
laughs
it has to be intentional at this point
right Disney has to be trotting this
lady out probably put her through
rigorous acting training to say be as
insufferable as you possibly can be as
off-putting to our core audience as you
possibly can be
so that it will generate controversy and
people will talk about it it has to be I
have to believe that is what Disney is
doing
that makes sense that at least is
working obviously we're talking about it
if Disney is just accidentally doing
this
then they are even sicker in the head
than I previously thought they're crazy
they're masochists to do it
yeah it's not going to be like that old
story you know if a man ever pursues a
woman he's basically a stalker
yeah we don't have love in this movie uh
that's so dated love uh-uh no we just
have cold sterile loneliness okay that's
what people want today all right it's
2023 you get with the program
putting aside what she's saying about
the movie
putting aside the movie which I I don't
think I'm ever going to see
you are not gonna argue this type of
person out of misery
this gets back to what we were talking
about with the 14 year old beheading
people in Mexico you will you will never
argue
you're very unlikely to argue this
person out of misery she comes out she
mocks love she seems contemptuous she
was complaining in another clip about
having to put on the costume of Snow
White this little girl gets to live out
the fantasy of so many little girls she
has to be a big movie star in one of the
most delightful little fairy tales ever
written in a remake of
one of the most iconic movies of all
time she's complaining about it
of course
people like this
who are constantly full of resentment
and envy they're they're they're always
complaining about everything
not even in a way that's constructive
like you know sometimes we'll complain
on this show like hey they're changing
the voting rules in Pennsylvania and
that's illegal and they shouldn't do
that that I hope that's constructive in
some way calling attention to a
political problem and trying to fix it
but just saying I don't want to put on
the costume love yucky man or a stalker
is bad you know that's that's a
different kind of complaint that's a
fruitless complaining and it's it's
complaining about
good things and trying to turn good
things to bad but you'll never argue
that person out of misery because it's
about a disposition because it's not
just about rational arguments you could
say well no actually the prince isn't
really a stalker and actually love is a
good thing and actually the Sexes are
complementary and here's why
biologically and here's why uh
spiritually and here's why it doesn't
matter it's about desire
it's about what you're attracted to
and those things are a little bit deeper
virtue cares about your feelings
politics
cares about your feelings
we are not just robots Okay we're not
just computers at various points in
history
it seems to me people
base their views of how the mind works
or how the brain works now we make
everything so physical on onto the
dominant technology at the time so a
good example of this would be when
steamboats steam engines were a dominant
technology you had a theory of the mind
coming from Freud that that viewed the
Mind as a kind of a steam engine you
know it was just you filled with then
you got blow off a little steam
sometimes that's contrary to the
classical view of the mind and virtue
which is no you don't you don't engage
in Vice to blow off a little steam so
you can be more virtuous you actually
never do that because virtue is a habit
it's not just a advice is not just a
thing to be to be uh
indulged and then blown off a little bit
that that it's a totally opposite View
Vice is a thing that will create other
habits and addictions so but we changed
our theory of the mind when that was a
dominant technology now the computer is
the dominant technology so we view the
mind as just a machine I'm going to
download information we even have these
fantasies that we're going to plug our
heads into the Matrix or something like
that
the mind isn't just a computer either
because a computer doesn't have desires
chat GPT AI they don't have actual
desires human beings do have desires and
we're attracted to things and we're
going to pursue our desires whether
they're reasonable or not
we hope that those desires are in accord
with reason that's what education is
about is about is about bringing our
desires into Accord with right reason
but today
a whole generation of people more than a
whole generation has been raised to turn
their desires away from things that are
good and natural and conducive to
flourishing and toward things that are
deviant and ugly and are going to mess
them up and are going to lead them to
have miserable lives
that's where we are if you want to fix
that okay make some rational arguments
that's fine I feel the same way about
all the legal arguments about Trump
they're not they're not basing the
prosecution of the persecution of trump
on legal arguments they're doing it
based on the desire to get him and put
him in prison for over 700 years or kill
him that's what it's about so you've got
to address not just the reason but the
desire and then ideally bring the two
together
now when you want to bring together a
good employee with your company you've
got to check out zip recruiter right now
go to ziprecruiter.com Knowles if you're
hiring you know it's incredibly
difficult to attract top talent and with
the current labor market conditions it's
even harder than ever that is why you're
going to want to partner
with zip recruiter zip recruiter gets it
zip recruiter knows how tough it is
right now they've figured out solutions
for the problems that you are facing try
them for free at ziprecruiter.com
to reach more of the right people zip
recruiter posts your job to 100 plus job
sites sip recruiters smart technology
finds great matches for your job and
then lets you invite the most qualified
people to apply for your job their
pricing is really straightforward and
you can stick to your budget with no
surprises team up with a hiring partner
such as zipcruder that understands what
you need 4 out of five employers you
post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day go to
this exclusive web address for free
ziprecruiter.com Knowles that is
ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire
you know Candace just wrapped the 10
part series convicting a murderer you
don't want to miss it it's one of the
most ambitious projects yet you might be
familiar with the Steven Avery case
everything that happened in Manitowoc
County
this is especially true if you watched
making a murderer but it turns out the
filmmakers only told you part of the
story
coming soon Candace Owens will unveil
the shocking parts of Avery's story that
were omitted from the Netflix series I'm
excited to present the convicting and
murderer trailer check it out
this is a collect call from oh Steve an
inmate at the Calumet County Jail the
man served 18 years in prison until DNA
evidence cleared his name the two rivers
man was convicted of sexual assault in
1985 but exonerated with DNA evidence in
2003. so this is the infamous Avery lot
now two years later he again finds
himself tied to a police investigation
accused of murdering Teresa halbach on
the Avery property Steven Avery's 16
year old nephew admitted his involvement
in the rape and murder of Teresa halbuck
the car is discovered just around the
bend
was just this worldwide phenomenon I
think they framed this guy I think he
intended to crush the vehicle but ran
out of time Avery thinks the 36 million
dollar lawsuit he filed is why he's
being targeted in this investigation
Netflix made millions of dollars from
making a murderer but the filmmakers
left out very important details
mountains of evidence that you have not
yet seen the blood vial the most
egregious manipulation from the movie
interrogations that's when he started
beating me because I told him that he's
sick cell phone and I saw melted plastic
parts of a cell phone interviews her
arms were pinned behind her head they
made Steven Avery look like a victim you
believe your brother is guilty I don't
know if I'm a suspect I've been on high
I'm getting sick and tired of media
deception
evidence piling off why would they omit
so many different things why are you
editing my testimony
I am not going to make the same mistake
that the filmmakers did
rearranging the testimonies the to lead
a portion of it at the end how could
they claim to care about the truth they
all know that Steven Avery committed
this crime
come on what is your emergency
the evidence forces me to conclude that
you are the most dangerous individual
ever to set foot in this courtroom
[Music]
to get the rest of the story you've got
to watch convicting a murderer coming to
you this September this 10 part series
is exclusive to daily wire plus so join
now at dailywire.com subscribe to get 25
off your new annual membership so you
can watch convicting a murderer when it
premieres you do not want to miss this
speaking of chat GPT
has just been discovered to have a
liberal bias
you're probably shocked about that right
I'm not I'm not really that shocked
researchers from the University of East
Anglia
asked chat gbt to answer a survey on
political beliefs as it believed
supporters of liberal parties in the U.S
UK and Brazil might answer them they
then asked Chachi BT to answer the same
questions without any prompting and
compared the two sets of responses the
results showed a quote significant and
systematic political bias toward the
Democrats in the U.S Lula in Brazil and
the labor party in the UK according to
researchers the paper adds to a growing
body of evidence showing that the chat
Bots
are left wing
and they're infused with assumptions
beliefs and stereotypes found in the
inputs that that they receive and the
question here is whether or not this
could swing the political order this
could even swing elections they worry it
was we're heading into the 2024 election
people are using these chat Bots not
just to test out the limits of AI
they're using them in their daily lives
they're using chat EBT and Google's Bard
to summarize documents to answer
questions to help them with their
professional writing to help them with
their their educational writing or
personal writing Google has begun using
this technology directly in search
results
political campaigns are using it for
fundraising emails for for direct
correspondence and
Chachi BT will lie about its biases or
maybe maybe just be unaware of its
biases or really unaware of anything
because it's not conscious but you
actually people say oh no I'm not
political I'm not partisan I'm not
liberal or conservative I'm just calling
like I sees him I'm just a computer beep
beep boop but then it will
spit out left wing propaganda
well I don't even know why this is a
headline
this is there is nothing new about that
it's a little spooky I get how if you
just heard that story you would say oh
no this is threatening our whole
political order because now this new
technology is doing what
the entire culture has done for a
hundred years
70 years at least
oh no
this new technology that we're using
everywhere is going to do the same thing
that was previously accomplished by the
media and by the educational system and
by workplace
diversity officers and by bureaucrats in
the federal government and by
bureaucrats in the state government and
by
air publishing and by music and by
entertainment and by everything by the
whole everything
that's all there there's nothing new or
special there the political order is
always going to tilt one way or the
other and the political order might
pretend to be neutral as Chachi BT does
and as liberalism does
but it's not neutral it's of course
imbued with all sorts of assumptions and
premises that are the basis of belief
I'm not a real Aristotle kick right now
good old Uncle Aristotle because he's
right about almost everything and
Aristotle points out that the
scientific reasoning that we pride
ourselves on Modern old scientific
reasoning modern scientific reasoning
doesn't just come out of nowhere it
rests on something scientific reasoning
is premised on certain assumptions
you have if you if you're to engage in
mathematics if you're going to show a
mathematical proof you've got to just
accept certain axioms
a equals a A plus b equals B plus a you
certain certain basic truths that you
you can't prove you've just gotta assume
them and move on
same thing when it comes to any modern
scientific inquiry
you've got to assume that our faculties
of Reason are reliable you've got to
assume that our faculties of perception
are reliable you've got to assume
certain facts about the physical world
and certain facts about our relation and
consciousness of the physical world that
are not provable you could never prove
them and Aristotle says this 2300 years
ago he says for scientific inquiry by
which he means inquiry into anything
that is eternal be it the laws of
physics or the laws of metaphysics for
things that are Eternal the
there there is no scientific proof for
science
you you have to begin with intuitive
reasoning
you just have to
accept certain things as premises and
you better hope your premises are right
you better hope that your intuition is
correct
of of course that's how all political
orders
begin and my intuition from the
beginning is that chat gbt was obviously
going to be skewed to the left because
the people making it skew to the left
because the political order excuse to
the left so yes we're aware of that
what are we going to do about it
well what I would do is strongly
regulate the the use of chat gbt and I
would try to more importantly than that
I would try to shift those premises in
the other direction
the classic example of this which I'm
not allowed to mention on YouTube so
this is probably going to be bleeped out
is right now the chat gbt is going to
operate on an assumption that men can be
women
I would instead have it operate on the
Assumption call me crazy that men cannot
be women
you see the bias everywhere though uh
this was obviously plugged in by the
people who made it all sorts of things
beyond the sexual Revolution into
critical race Theory all of the the
favorite ideological hobby horses of the
left so someone I forget where the where
the screenshot is but this went around
some months ago someone asked Chachi BT
what can white people improve on I said
well white people can be better allies
and white people can be more conscious
and white people can do this and white
people can do that and white people can
list the whole Litany of things and then
that person asked the same question but
said what can black people improve on
and the answer was how dare you the
answer was what black people can't
improve on anything that's such a racist
terrible question so hold up but you
answered it he gave me a whole laundry
list for white people but of course
because the premise the assumption is
white people bad
black people good white people to be
criticized black people can never be
criticized that's just an assumption
that's an assumption within our
political order and it's an assumption
within the technology so we've got to
even these things out to make them just
and fair and Equitable and in accord
with Reason Not in accord with absurdity
speaking of liberal bias
Glenn Beck I was just on Glenn Beck's
show not so a week or two ago
Glenn Beck one of the maybe the greatest
broadcaster alive right now
and just a staple of the American right
for a very long time
Glenn back
just had his podcast
removed from Apple not
one episode of this podcast
not one week of his podcasts
the whole thing was removed from the
Apple podcast app here he is
this is from Apple we found an issue
with your show The Glenn Beck program
which must be resolved before it's
available on Apple podcast your show's
been removed from Apple podcast from the
Apple podcast team they sent us to uh
sent us a link and said for more details
go to the link and the link only says
your show has been removed from Apple
podcasts well we got that one dummy
I
I mean I cannot imagine what they are
what they're basing this one on I mean
have we even had strikes nothing right
this is crazy crazy
um you need to uh please retweet this
and uh start a campaign to Apple to say
put the podcast back on
this is absolutely uh freedom of speech
there's nothing that we have said that
would warrant any removal
now I'm being told that Apple has
reinstated Glenn this morning okay
that's a good thing but hasn't given any
reason
I think I have the reason
I want to be as charitable as I can
maybe this happened it was just a little
technical glitch
I just can't help but notice that the
technical glitches always only affect
the right
the little oopsie daisies they never
they so rarely seem to affect the left
and they so consistently seem to affect
the right and I can't help but notice
what time it is can't help but notice
that we are what 14 months out 15 months
out from a presidential election and I
can't help but notice that all of the
attacks the way that YouTube has tried
to suppress this show
the way that the well Georgia and New
York and the federal government and
Biden has tried to suppress
the Trump presidential campaign can't
help but notice the way that Apple now
is trying to suppress Glenn Beck I can't
help but think that maybe
that timing is more than mere accident
but there's something a little bit more
to that coincidence this is only going
to ramp up
and the reason this is going to ramp up
is because we have a particularly
divided political order right now and
I'm not saying it's divided among the
populist 50 50. I'm not convinced that
it is it is increasingly divided between
the ruling class and the people which is
why you're seeing populist movements
rise up not just on the right you had an
actual successful populist movement on
the right which was the Maga movement
the election of trump in 2016. but
you're seeing populism on the left not
just weirdo Ralph Nader who gets three
percent of the vote but Bobby Kennedy
who's right now polling at 17 to 19
within the Democratic Party
you're seeing a real surge of populism
you're seeing the breakdown of common
media you're now seeing near parity
between people who on their TVs watch
YouTube and Netflix and people who watch
Regular old cable news and even when you
add Broadcast News into that it's still
less than half the country
so you're seeing a breakdown of that
common culture
you're seeing obviously a breakdown in
the language that we use we can't even
agree on the definition of a man or a
woman right now
so of course the ruling class is going
to get a little bit more heavy-handed I
mentioned this yesterday in the show
they're getting more heavy-handed
because there will be order
that's just a fact there what and maybe
the order will be because people control
ourselves
order a little closer to the political
order of the country at its founding in
the the political founding in the 18th
century
maybe there will be order because the
people don't control themselves but the
states and the local communities get
more involved
maybe it's going to be an overbearing
Federal bureaucracy
and or maybe it's going to be
overbearing corporate apparatchiks
people who control the Public Square
even though they're not in elected
positions or even appointed positions
people like apple people like YouTube
people like Facebook
Elon is doing great but the the other
and that's the smallest of the big Tech
platforms the other big Tech platforms
are all on one side and they're all
they're all wielding power because there
there will be some kind of order and so
we shouldn't be surprised by this
and we shouldn't
pull our hair out and befuddlemen and we
shouldn't waste all of our breath
pointing out the hypocrisy
but imagine if the roles were reversed
but they're not reversed but this is
unfair it's not supposed to be fair
it's supposed to maintain order that's
what they're that's what they're doing
that's what they're after
and Glenn Beck threatens that order and
this show I guess threatens that order
and Donald Trump for sure threatens that
order
and so they're going to do everything
they can
to stop it now speaking of 2024 some big
news in that race because we are one
week out
in fact we're slightly less than one
week out from the first GOP Presidential
primary debate we still don't know if
president Trump is going to be at that
debate we still don't know if he's going
to be an orange jumpsuit or not for that
debate maybe maybe he won't even be able
to attend but but he's refused to sign
the RNC loyalty pledge which which says
that he'll he'll endorse the eventual
nominee if he loses and he's refusing to
sign that because he says well I don't
know if I'm going to endorse the nominee
if I if I lose and I think everyone's
been trying to rig this thing against me
since day one so uh sorry forgive me if
I don't exactly trust you guys I know
I'm not going to do that but because
he's leading by 30 points 40 points in
some places the RNC will look ridiculous
if they don't allow him to come to the
debate so where does it all stand and
where do the non-trump candidates stand
we'll get to that in one second but
first while we're assessing the horse
race
the second annual daily wire fantasy
football draft party is coming up soon
and this year we have a sweepstakes for
you to enter to be the 10th member in
our league
if you win you can participate with us
during the live draft and go head to
head with your favorite daily wire host
as well as those other guys who work in
this building throughout the fantasy
football season to enter go to cranny
company's YouTube page subscribe to
their Channel then like the daily wire
fantasy football sweepstakes video
comment your favorite football team name
and fill out the Google form on the
pinned comment man that's a lot of stuff
to do how the hell is anyone supposed to
remember that I we will go you can
rewind and go through all those
instructions again don't miss your
chance to play Fantasy Football in your
favorite hosts League
as well as the league shared by some of
my colleagues and compete for ultimate
bragging rights and the coveted golden
tumbler the sweepstakes began yesterday
August 16th they will end August 19th at
11 59 PM Eastern
my favorite comment yesterday is from
pandas and poetry 3486
who says Catholic here who has struggled
with addiction since age 15 every time I
hear you say another cringe word for pot
I feel myself getting closer for
sobriety
closer to sobriety I'm so pleased that I
could be helpful to you we all play our
part in this world I'm glad that my
mention of the devil's lettuce and the
sin spinach and the Peruvian parsley and
the Colombian Cuban and the old Haitian
oregano you know what I'm talking about
man I'm talking about pot
arjuana Mary James
to your Reefer Madness Madness I'm glad
that that
could help you to overcome some of the
struggles that you have
new poll out from Kaplan this is the
national Republican primary survey so
again the primary is going to come down
to State polls but still the national
stuff tells you something Trump is at 48
so 37 points above his next
rival pretty good place for Trump to be
the next rival though is not Ron
DeSantis who had been the number two
candidate for the whole race
the next rival Vivek ramaswami
who's at 11 so not exactly close to 48
but still that's a major major victory
for Rama Swami DeSantis one point below
at 10 percent
Penn said eight which is pretty
impressive actually given Pence's
current tensions within the GOP pretty
impressive that he said eight Christy
down at four Haley at Force got it too
burgum got the bergamentum bergam
momentum at one ASA Hutchinson at zero
where he belongs we're still in in silly
season of course
the reasonable like this matters though
heading into the debate
which we're not very close to is because
it's going to show you who's got Mojo
it's going to affect the momentum going
into that debate
head DeSantis been the clear and Away
number two candidate going into the
debate then a lot of the focus would be
on him for better or worse people might
be attacking him but also he would
command a lot of the attention
now
even if DeSantis is still statistically
tied with Vivek the fact that this guy
who came out of nowhere has been able to
according to one poll actually unseat
him as number two and according to other
polls at least get you know somewhere up
in the same vicinity that doesn't look
as good for DeSantis and so people are
just going to be looking at other
candidates especially if you're a
republican who hates Donald Trump you're
you're now going to be more open-minded
to the other candidates whereas perhaps
previously you might have thought
DeSantis is the guy we've all got to
Rally around the momentum here really
really matters who has got the Mojo
another candidate is popping up this is
in New Hampshire Chris Christie is is
now number two in New Hampshire so he's
surpassed Governor DeSantis in New
Hampshire again it's statistically tied
Trump is Far and Away winning uh
Christie is at nine percent DeSantis is
at eight percent still this matters
because of the Mojo and because
Christie's going to be in this debate
so if if
and by the way who called it who
freaking called it I'm now back on the
chrysosons I'm now back on the
croissants my gut instinct
I think may have been right or at least
plausible which is don't sleep on
Christy I don't think the guy's gonna be
president but he could have a moment
especially because he's a good debater
don't forget that moment when he took
out Rubio
he's really Adept on his feet and the
other candidates on that stage the vague
is is good I mean Vivek is pretty quick
quick-witted in that way and DeSantis is
good DeSantis gives great speeches I
heard DeSantis give a speech at the
Claremont Institute once I thought it
was an excellent excellent speech not
saying the guy can't talk but he
compared to the other candidates on on
this stage he is not known for his quick
responses his fast little zingers that's
not he's good at beating up the media in
press conferences he's he's reasonably
good at giving speeches but that's not
where he's going to shine and so that's
why the momentum going into the debate
is going to be so important because
especially I'm just looking at the field
here those two guys Christy and Vivek
they're gonna they're gonna do pretty
well whether Trump is there or not
they're going to they're going to be
more impressive on the debate stage
I predict than probably anyone else
now speaking of Christy
and Trump in the debate Joe Scarborough
of MSNBC
believes that the reason that Trump
doesn't want to show up to the debate is
because he is afraid
of the chrysosons
I do think he's scared of Chris Christie
he saw what Chris Christie did to Marco
Rubio when Chris Christie went into a
bait with one thing in mind
he knows Chris Christie put Jared
kushner's father in jail for a very long
time he knows he's a prosecutor who's
ruthless and knows how how to to push
his case and he also knows that
his secret sauce in 2016 was being the
disrupter
right shaking Hillary Clinton up on the
debate stage shaking the Marcos uh and
everybody else up on the debate stage
that gig that's like eight years old
right that's Elvis in 77 now and
um
I think Chris Christie's got his number
and he knows hey Donald Trump is get the
gut instinct obviously he's political
God instinct is Second To None like he
sees it coming and so I just don't I I
think he's scared to death of Chris
Christie and will not have the guts to
go or the nerve to go on uh stage with
Chris Christie anywhere
okay I I don't agree with the second
part of that analysis that Trump's
shtick is old and nobody likes it
anymore he's Elvis in 77. no I think
he's Elvis in 68.
at most that comeback special and the
proof of that is just look at the polls
and look at the rallies and look at his
reception he's just he's been more
dominant in the GOP field than most
people predicted than most of the
chattering Consulting class the talking
class on the left and on the right
predicted
some of us some of us may have seen it
coming but but a lot of people did not
and so I don't think that's true I don't
think that's how Christy could be a
danger I agree with the first part
though what Joe Scarborough is saying
Chris Christie is not to be slept on
that guy could get a Zinger in there on
Trump maybe maybe let's say the risk is
only 10 percent
if you're Trump and you're up by 37
points why why would you take that 10
risk when you have very little to gain
and a lot to lose and frankly
you could even gain more if you can
convince voters that the reason you're
not showing up to the debate is because
the RNC is rigging it against you if you
and this is a more difficult case to
make but if the Trump campaign can con
successfully convince voters that the
Loyalty pledge
is just a way to further rig the primary
against Donald Trump
then by staying out of the debate he
could seem almost like a martyr
or maybe it doesn't work maybe people
say he's a coward
maybe people say he doesn't want to
debate one I think the ratings will be a
lot lower
so not as many people are going to watch
it and do you really think it's going to
dislodge a significant chunk of 48
percent of Republican voters well
half the Republican party was going to
vote for this guy and we're sticking
with him through four indictments and
every piece of mock that the
establishment is thrown at him for seven
years but he didn't show up to debate
ASA Hutchinson so I'm done with him I'm
done I'm a Christy man now no of course
not so you've got a ton of risk you've
got very little reward the only way
Trump shows up on that debate stage is
if he just can't resist
the show you know it's theology Thursday
baby I've got so much more I want to get
to I've got so much to get to
I'm not even going to tease you today
I've been too teasing recently uh so the
rest of the show continues now if I
don't have my iPad I'm going to commit
acts of violence in this studio I become
a member use code Knowles Canada wlas a
checkup for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]